es una sábana bordeada por ríos que se
extiende sobre más de 2 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados cuatro veces
francia en el corazón de brasil el
cerrado está siendo mordisqueado por la
agricultura intensiva desde hace más de
20 años los campos de soya y algodón
conforman círculos hasta donde alcanza
la vista
es el dorado de helio hop uno de estos
colonos provenientes del sur del país
que vino buscando espacios llegué aquí
en 1992 todo esto era cerrado
transformados en pivotes estos campos
tienen una forma redondeada para
facilitar que los inmensos sistemas de
riego puedan girar alrededor de sí
mismos
gira en su centro y se detiene enfada es
el inicio de la temporada de siembra de
soya el yodo debe regar a 1500 hectáreas
en tiempo récord en la región el riego
artificial de estos pivotes es
autorizado tan solo algunos días al mes
y por unas cuantas horas
hoy en día producir alimentos no es
fácil y es por ello que somos héroes con
todas esas leyes medioambientales que
existen en brasil por estos días más
exigentes que en otros países pues bien
somos nosotros brasil el país que más
protege el medio ambiente
somos héroes denunciados por
asociaciones medioambientales que los
acusan de afectar el bosque y sus
recursos de agua el agricultor está
decidido a probar nuestro contrario
estas instalaciones son sólo para llegar
al río
todo esto alrededor es una reserva
protegida miren sólo instalamos estas
tuberías para obtener el agua que
necesitamos es todo de fort estamos nada
muy pronto si la gente sigue diciendo
que estamos destruyendo el río pararemos
de sembrar y que comerá entonces la
gente
piedras asfalto edificios y cemento
concreto
a unos cuantos kilómetros de aquí en la
pequeña comunidad de río branco manuel
ozono y sus vecinos sufren sin embargo
de lleno las consecuencias del
agrobusiness
para destacar todo proviene de este
reservorio
miren lo débil que está el caudal las
120 familias de agricultores que viven
aquí tuvieron que rivalizar con ingenio
para llevar agua del río hasta sus
campus con un caudal cada vez más del
agua yo obtengo el agua gracias a este
molino el agua pasa por este tubo hace
20 años el nivel de agua estaba más
elevado que esta es un afluente del río
são francisco que atraviesa cinco
estados del norte del país el agro
business se asentó en las reservas de
agua de brasil duración
consecuencias medioambientales pero
también humanas a varias horas de
carretera por río branco bienvenido a la
finca strong de un consorcio de río
acusado por numerosas asociaciones como
greenpeace de haberse apropiado
ilegalmente de más de 400.000 hectáreas
[Música]
todo esto era cerrado nativo en la
tierra pública
se lo apropiaron de manera fraudulenta
fraudulenta a mí
el austriaco martin mail denuncia la
presencia de strong dow desde hace 20
años en la amazonía la ley obliga a los
agricultores a preservar el 80% de los
bosques de su terreno aquí tan solo el
20 por ciento la empresa vio una mina de
oro en este cerrado muy vigilado desde
estos puestos de control
i
hola queremos llegar a la ciudad
a su paso por aquí están prohibidos
me conoce
finalmente debemos desviarnos durante
dos horas siempre es así martín
la última vez que tratamos de pasar y
fue violento
la lucha de martín male y las
comunidades rurales tradicionales que
viven en las tierras de strong dow
reivindica les generan numerosas
amenazas hola cómo están estos granjeros
no conducen a un puesto de control
instalado recientemente por la empresa a
unos cuantos metros de su casa
los vigilantes están allá también
cuentan con una patrulla que tapona la
vía aquí hacíamos pastar nuestro ganado
y vivíamos del cerrado
y sobrevive de los que están calmados
porque usted está aquí de lo contrario
estarían apuntándonos con sus armas
guarda de hace un año en un puesto
vecino a josué lópez le confiscaron
vacas el granjero trató de recuperarlas
i
su pierna queda herida por la bala entró
por aquí aquí las comunidades
denunciaron estos abusos
durante la pandemia hubo nuevos
enfrentamientos
son a todo el mundo
martín viene a aconsejar los que nos
acusan de haber quemado sus tierras
cuando ni tenemos acceso a ellas no
sabemos quién lo hizo
la fiscalía podría llamar a la policía
como refuerzo para verificar todo esto
trataremos de convencerlos estos
granjeros viven en estas tierras desde
hace más de dos siglos sin ningún título
de propiedad pero gracias a martín y su
asociación ganaron el pleito hace tres
años este documento significa que la
justicia reconoce que estas tierras
pertenecen a las familias de esta
comunidad
pero es pronto tiene excelentes
contactos políticos amigos entre
representantes de la justicia es por
ello que es un poco la lucha de david
contra goliat pero sabe quién gana al
final es david
un documento que strong dono ha
respetado al día de hoy por el contrario
el consorcio obtuvo hace poco la
autorización de deforestar 25 mil nuevas
hectáreas en la región un acaparamiento
ilegal de tierra récord en el cerrado y
oscuras horas por venir para las
pequeñas comunidades rurales de los
alrededores